I'm getting the same amount of pizza.
Even though the fraction one-fourth
looks different than the fraction
two-eighths, they are actually
equivalent fractions.
I'm still getting one-fourth
of the pizza, but
my portion of the pizza has been
cut into two slices instead of one.
I can show that they're equivalent by
finding a common factor in the numerator
and the denominator.
The factors of 2 are 1 and 2.
The factors of 8 are 1, 2, 4, and 8.
The greatest common factor
that they share is 2.
We usually don't consider 1 when
finding the greatest common factor.
Because 2 and 8 have factors in common,
we can write two-eighths
in a different way.
2 can also be written as 2 x 1.
And 8 can be written as 2 x 4
because 2 x 4 is 8 and 2 x 1 is 2.
If I divide out the 2
in the numerator and
the 2 in the denominator,
I am left with one-fourth.